يوجد اتجاهان في جبهه الانقاذ الوطني
احدهما يدعو لمقاطعه الانتخابات واخر مع
المشاركه مع توحد الجبهه تحت قائمه
موحده رؤيتك ليست بمقاطعه
الانتخابات لا ليس الان فانا ارى باستحقاق
هذا الراي اي بالمقاطعه ولكنني اتواصل
لرؤيه اداره عودتنا للانتخابات فجميعنا
سنقرر ذلك واذا ما قررنا جميعنا المقاطعه
يكون ذلك موقف موحد للمعارضه هذا اولا اما
ثانيا فنحن جميعنا متفقون بان توقيت
الانتخابات سيء جدا وعلمنا من البنك
المركزي بانه في شهري ابريل نيسان ومايو
ايار القادمين ستكون هنالك مشكله اقتصاديه
وماليه كبيره في الحقيقه اقترحت انت في
منتصف الشهر الحالي الانتظار سته اشهر قبل
اجراء الانتخابات نعم صحيح لكن البلد ليس
جاهزا لذلك البلد ليس جاهزا وفي الحقيقه
نريد حكومه وحده وطنيه تقود البلاد في ظل
الظروف الراهنه وكل الاحزاب والقوى
السياسيه عليها الجلوس معا ومحاوله النهوض
بالوضع وهذا يتطلب برايي وراي الكثير من
المصريين ايضا تاجيل الانتخابات وهذا ما
طلبناه ولكننا الان نواجه بقرار الحكومه
اجراء الانتخابات في غضون شهرين وهذا ما
وعد به بعضنا لمقاطعه
الانتخابات انت لا تتفق بالوقت الراهن مع
محمد البردعي وتعتقد بان خطوته بعيده
لا ليست بعيده كثيرا وهو يمثل راي قطاع
معين داخل جبهه الانقاذ الوطني ولكن هناك
راي اخر وهو ان نذهب ونخوض معركه
الانتخابات ولكن علينا ان نتوافق جميعا
اما المضي قدما او
المقاطعه